the big guns are out in the final days
before the midterm elections the
Democrats won't need to generate a big
turnout this election is not a
referendum
it's a choice it's a choice
between two vastly different Visions for
America
traditionally the party in the White
House can expect to get hammered and the
polls are pointing that way Joe Biden's
law approval rating doesn't help voters
when they can't vote at the top of the
ticket use elections as a referendum on
the party in power and so most the time
the president's party loses seats in the
House during midterm elections losing
the house could spell real problems for
Joe Biden's agenda and Legacy since he
took power inflation has spiked prices
for food and gas have risen his
successes in cutting drug prices
addressing climate change rebuilding
infrastructure is not energizing voters
Republicans want to end the January 6th
hearings investigate Biden for as yet
unspecified reasons reform how payments
are made to U.S seniors and some are
pushing for a restrictive National
Abortion law Biden can veto some of that
but not all an energized Republican
party could shrink his presidency as
with any president that exists in a
divided government it will be much more
difficult for him to get anything done
and as we know in an air of polarization
what we've experienced in the last 30
plus years is that presidents in divided
government have a very difficult time
passing their agenda many Republicans
running this time round believe the last
presidential election was stolen and
they won't commit to accept the result
if they lose that leaves many experts
worried that this could undermine the
whole election process if there is any
sort of uh massive kind of error there
are challenges there are recounts there
are audits so to not concede to refuse
to accept the results as long as all of
those processes have been gone through
is just further erodes trust in the
system the pain of the economy remains
voters top concern a hammering here
could leave Biden not just unable to
push his agenda things are looking good
but might damage him so badly the idea
idea of running again in 2024 could be
ended right here Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Washington